[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here welcome back to
a brand new video and we got a little
bit of an exclusive for you today which
are always fun now look we're always
talking about new pieces of tech on this
channel but you got to take a step back
sometimes and think and just remember
how smart some of the ai
in this tech is getting like we just saw
the boston dynamics robot dog and even
their newest packaging robot
but this stuff
this is next level so today i'm
reviewing the most advanced tech i've
looked at yet on this channel i'm
reviewing the newest edition mac
one of one colorway which is it's kind
of this unique thing like one of the rim
acts from that last dope tech video
where every single one is different this
is a one of one but it's super cool
let's get into it
so we've had this new mac at the studio
through its development for a couple
years now through several software
updates we've actually had a pretty big
hand in the development of it and we've
put it through its paces tested the
hardware the software and the features
and there's a lot to it so if you're one
of the lucky people actually considering
getting this model or one like it well
then this video is for you so actually
when we first got the mac here at the
studio it was lightly used it wasn't
original it didn't have the original
packaging
so we didn't get to do an on-camera
unboxing but that's fine
when you first get them they actually
have way less features and then you sort
of get to uh evolve them over time so
first of all basic specs this is the
mid-size version in the mocha cream
color about 30 pounds fun fact too every
unit sold is a unique colorway like i
said and a lot of them look like pretty
similar but there was lots of small
details on each unit that would be just
a little bit different and appreciated
by the person who gets it then this
model has a soft touch finish that
actually slowly changes over time and
overall i'd say build quality is solid
sturdy it's pretty easy to wash although
i'd recommend taking it to a certified
cleaner they usually do a better job so
the mac didn't come with any sort of
screen protector or case or bumpers or
anything like that
but i've generally found you don't
actually need one they're pretty sturdy
and well built without one but if you do
get one just know that they're a pretty
rough sizing model it's not the same
exact cutouts for every single one but
if you get one just make sure yours
doesn't cover the ventilation system at
the front or the exhaust system at the
back so you've got a bunch of sensors up
at the front this is where the action
happens so there's dual monochrome
sensors with autofocus assist by this
middle sensor that the manufacturer
calls a snout sensor but it seems to
operate the exact same way that laser
autofocus does meaning it just helps the
main sensors so like if you covered it
up it would still work it could still
take in the surroundings but it's kind
of just like the same as laser autofocus
also there's a pair of microphones one
on either side for audio processing for
voice commands so all these sensors put
together help the mac to navigate
surroundings and not bump into things
that moves around its environment so i
just want to say battery life
is okay
but it's not amazing it's really not
great a lot of these new technologies we
give a pass because they're so novel and
so cool that we'll focus on battery life
in later generations this one you need
to charge by the end of the day every
time
uh the way you charge isn't necessarily
how you'd expect there is no usb port i
looked trust me uh but there are a bunch
of other ways to potentially charge up
so it's got fast charging in the form of
this energy transfer with any number of
first party made for mac materials and
they're great you can literally just buy
a box of them but of course there are a
bunch of other materials that they say
you're not supposed to power it with but
if you're in a pinch they'll technically
still work they're just not quite as
efficient probably the safest way to
power the mac is the optional wireless
charging pad it doesn't come with this
but i would highly recommend it it's
pretty convenient for charging up
overnight and the software even has this
sweet built-in auto docking feature
where it automatically returns to the
charging pad when the battery gets low
and the sensors turn off the software
goes to sleep it's just kind of this
slower overnight trickle charge but it's
a stable one so the rest of the software
is pretty solid uh from what i gather
they're all programmed just a little bit
differently this one's programmed with
the best friend security guard features
uh
slightly different for every model but
it works so it's programmed to identify
a few best friends and then guard those
best friends from outside threats so
when we got into the studio all the ai
and the sensors immediately looked over
the environment identified the entryways
and just went into protection mode so i
guess that's how it delivers out the box
and it's very consistent every delivery
every visitor every person walking past
the door alarm system max volume
but everything else runs as you might
expect through voice controls kind of
like any other piece of tech probably
would in 2021 so it's got these mics on
either side and it's got the trigger
phrase so you just say hey mac
get them
and it knows the trigger phrase and it's
the processing time has gotten shorter
over the years through software updates
which is dope
but there are some quirks so first of
all it can take a while to install new
programs sometimes days sometimes weeks
especially games and sometimes you have
to reinstall them a few times before
they work but eventually the ai gets it
and there is this weird bug where the
fetch game force quits in the middle of
the game for no reason not sure why but
maybe that can be fixed through a patch
then mac also has a high performance
sport mode where everything just flies
but if you're gonna use that mode just
know you're gonna be cruising through
the battery so you'll for sure have to
charge at least once to make it through
the end of the day after that
still pretty worth it to use this mode
every once in a while because the mac is
way more enjoyable to own when you got
this mode but most of all i think future
versions are going to want to work on
this sensor layout i mean
the audio is pretty great
and visual pickup is nice but i feel
like there's so much data going in that
the os isn't quite processing at all
maybe it just needs more ram i guess
don't we all but like sometimes the
snout sensor will lock on to one thing
and then throw off the whole rest of the
autofocus system sometimes if you give
it the wrong type of energy too many
times the ai learns and starts thinking
it's seeing energy all over the place
through those sensors and it basically
prioritizes all those false positives
over everything else trying to keep its
battery full sometimes you'll give it a
single voice command through the
triggers and it will just blast through
a series of commands like there's some
sort of a script loop in the software
and it can be a lot now when it does run
hot there is an active cooling system up
front like i mentioned and it does make
a little bit of noise sometimes usually
not too bad in this particular model
some other models are way noisier
and might expel a little bit of water
but other than that it's fine it might
just sound a little weird if you're not
expecting it
but it's fine but i gotta say the best
friend mode is flawless some would argue
it's the least important mode i'd argue
it's the most important it can keep you
company hang out with you
and i'd actually say this mode is
flawless some people have reservations
about an ai keeping them company i think
this one's great and if you're ever in
doubt that the system isn't running
smoothly that huge slider on the back
acts as a digital well-being indicator
so basically the faster it's moving the
happier that ai is
i'm no expert like we rate dogs but i'd
like to think mac is at least an 11 out
of 10. so that's been it uh thanks for
watching happy april fool's day in case
you haven't looked at the date below yet
this has been the review of mac that
everyone's wanted for so long yes that's
its actual name
uh this is your annual reminder not to
take anything you read on the internet
today
too seriously catch you guys in the next
one
peace
[Music]
hey what's up i'm kbhd here and
yeah that's probably
[Music]
if you do get one
don't cover the ventilation there's like
hair
processing for voice commands
you said a trigger phrase so this one's
hey mac
go get that
so this one's got a trigger phrase so
you just say hey mac get him get him so
first of all it can take a while to
install
you're back
you're back okay